there's a group mop it's like
liberal Nazis
that will go up and attack you like I
said
you know everyone's like Anna Winters
your friend I'm like
this Gabby girl
and Gigi and these people
um they would have never said anything
negative unless they got the okay from
condonaz unless they got the okay from
Anna
they would have never got the okay to
comment like let's just talk about
specifically so these are people who are
attacking you for your T-shirt well it
was a setup
it started off as
it started off as
them having
this black girl comment and say well I
felt traumatized when I saw
this t-shirt it's like a black girl
saying I felt traumatized when I saw
um
a black man wearing something that he
wasn't allowed to wear it's like in
Django when Jamie Foxx is on top of a
horse and Samuel Jackson's like
you know that black guy's not supposed
to be on top of the horse okay and then
I went and said hey I don't like your
boots I know Anna winter doesn't like
your boots and you're not a fashion
person
and then people started to say I was a
bully
but it was a setup
and they finally got it right because I
eliminated the the BLM officer at Adidas
and then I
got out of the Gap deal and just one by
one by one I just be I've been winning
these battles right and they thought
they had me they had the idea that yay
was bullying
uh what I think the term the liberal
term is uh a body goes black
woman now let's talk about Gabby and my
good friend lizzo lizzo works with my
trainer a friend of mine Harley past
that Harley Pasternak when lizzo loses
10 pounds and announces it the Bots
that's a term for uh people like it's
like telemarketer called callers like on
Instagram they attack her for losing
weight because the media wants to put
out a perception that being overweight
is the new goal when it's actually
unhealthy let's get aside the fact of
whether it's fashion and Vogue which is
not let's let's just or if someone
thinks is attractive to each his own
it's actually clinically
unhealthy
and for people to owe to promote that
um
it's a it's demonic
you know what I ask you I've noticed
this also yeah why do you think they
would want to promote unhealthiness
among the population it's a genocide of
the black race they want to kill us in
any way they can Planned Parenthood was
made by Margaret Sanger
a known Eugenics with the KKK and I
believe that if we saw ourselves as more
as we saw ourselves as a people and at a
race then we would treat our people
better like if you go to a Jewish person
and you say a race it's it almost gets
confusing it'll cut you off quickly and
say we're not a race
we're a people
well
are people supposed to just say Say It
Loud I'm Black and I'm Proud okay well
what about
do you own the land
that you're living in
do you own is the contracts even in a
language that's even possibly
understandable right you know for your
heritage you know
and
in America we as blacks will like down
each other
on how good we speak
but we're speaking English
there's nothing whiter than English
we're not in our native tongue actually
so we judge each other
on White
uh goal lines
not based on exactly what our culture is
based on
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight